BTS new video with Nicki Minaj and they
kicked off their North American tour
everything's lit Beyonce's latest
Instagram made me cry and cardi B keeps
it real at New York Fashion Week all
right you guys I'm having a real fanboy
moment today so bear with me because it
is not every day we hear from Beyonce
directly and today she had a special
message for it the Beehive just two days
after celebrating her 37th birthday he
shared some personal pictures of her and
J being all kinds of cute they took a
break from their on the run to tour for
a little bday getaway in Italy they
drank they ate cake and between giving
birth to twins renewing her vows with
jay-z Coachella the joint album and
touring the world Beyonce herself took
some time to reflect telling fans quote
this year has been monumental for me I
thank God for everyone in my life thank
you for all the positivity and for the
beautiful birthday wishes I'm looking
forward to continuing to learn from my
past living in the present and
surrendering to the future I love you
hive I think she's talking to me now is
she talking to us and thank you girl I
stand a queen but you guys know this
just like I stand the kings of kpop BTS
the guys just released their new music
video for Idol with the queen of rap
Nicki Minaj and we're not worthy
you see that to music tightens together
in one video is almost too much to
handle the internet is shaking so I'll
tell you what it doesn't compare to the
energy at Staples Center in LA last
night
that's where BTS kicked off their North
American leg of the love yourself world
tour I was there for the first of their
four sold-out nights here in LA and it
felt like a one-of-a-kind experience one
that I wanted to share with the army and
take you guys with me so I did all right
after being so lucky to interview them a
couple of times I'm finally see you beat
yesterday's bias
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
guys they are the real deal and I talk
about them so much because I know their
fans are so dedicated and I just tweeted
this today but seeing that kind of
talent live and vibing off everyone in
that crowd is literally why I love
concerts I'm proud to be a member of the
BTS army and I got a super alright and
from now from LA to the Big Apple et is
on the ground at New York Fashion Week
our first stop Tom Ford's presentation
that's where my girl Kristin Gill got
the one-and-only cardi B who was looking
all so fierce after give after giving
birth to her baby culture in July but
it's her style off the red carpet
Kristin learn is where she keeps it real
real Tom Ford has a scent called F and
fabulous oh my god you're insane when do
you feel F and fabulous I feel effing
fabulous after I finish taking a shower
and I take my wig off and I just feel
refreshed and I be like you know what I
got these prisoner braids but I'm still
beYOU know that's when I feel fabulous
so what's your fashion guilty pleasure
real quick do you have like an old
sweatshirt you like to wear when you are
stripped down like without the wig my
fashion guilty pleasure is spending
money that's you know as a as many money
is just beauty what inspired these this
I look tonight your makeups incredible
well you know makeup hair always got to
match the look you know what I'm saying
it like you've always got a match
everything can you believe that these
these are the nails they're arm I have
from the VMAs I gotta go
yep oh they're a little grown out but
you wouldn't even
yeah she's amazing you know what else is
amazing we just launched ET style we're
giving you new york fashion week we're
giving you tutorials and celeb styling
tips like how to wear a white t-shirt so
go look your flies and I'll see you guys
tomorrow for new music Friday
[Music]